China and Russia may not officially be
allies but they increasingly appear to
be Marching In step
one year on from the invasion of Ukraine
Beijing continues to tout its
partnership with Moscow as one Without
Limits and joint military drills like
this one have become commonplace
about China and Russia relations have
maintained a healthy and stable momentum
of development and incorporation in
various fields and this has yielded
fruitful results
one of those fruitful results is a
potential upcoming trip by President Xi
Jinping to Moscow in Spring
the Chinese leader counts Vladimir Putin
as a close friend and the two have met
in person 40 times including in Beijing
days before Russia attacked Ukraine in
but there's more to this than just
friendship Western sanctions have
prompted trade between Russia and China
to soar especially in energy Moscow is
beijing's largest supplier of oil and a
major supplier of piped and liquefied
natural gas
China really is a big winner in terms of
having more access to cheaper now
Uh Russian gas and Russian oil there's
also a realization in Beijing that
because it does really have the upper
hand now in terms of you know a source
for of investment for Russia uh that it
can more or less call the shots despite
providing Moscow with significant
economic support Beijing insists it's
neutral when it comes to the war in
Ukraine it's called on the two sides to
engage in peace talks
but U.S researchers say Chinese
state-armed firms are providing Russia
with sensitive Technologies to equip its
War Machine
the data explicitly says that these
parts are are being sent to Russia for
the use of the s-400 and M system
helicopters so we know that they're very
clearly stated for that use we also
understand that in general this
bilateral trade is growing and so we
believe that there might be some some
connections in both China's effort to
bolster its military capacity as well as
Russia's effort to bolster its military
capacity with Chinese goods and parts
Beijing calls these claims hyped up
fiction and says its ties with Moscow
are based on non-confrontation
beijing's refusal to condemn Russia's
invasion of Ukraine has frustrated
Western attempts to isolate the country
experts say International focus on the
war has proved useful for China
providing an ongoing distraction from
its own military activities in the South
China Sea and around Taiwan
Katrina you Al Jazeera Beijing